- All right, y'all, it's almost
time to roll the credits,
but I wanna squeeze in
one last, very cool story.
This is "What I'm Liking."
(cheerful music)
(audience applauding)
So you may not realize,
but nearly three million grandparents
are raising their own grandkids.
God bless 'em.
Still many of them struggle to get by.
So a woman in Las Vegas is
trying to make it easier
for grandparents in her community
through a program called "Grants 4 Grands"
which is the cutest program title.
Let's welcome Joyce, everybody.
(audience cheering)
Hi, Joyce.
Hi.
So this was born
out of another community
effort you led, right?
- Yes, it's Lace, the
nonprofit organization,
and we assist new needy
families and needy individuals
with emergency food and hygiene items.
About 15 years ago, we
noticed there was a increase
of grandparents coming to get assistance.
And so out of that, I created
the project "Grants 4 Grands"
so that we could assist these grandparents
that needed a little extra help.
They may have been
eligible for food stamps,
but you can't buy Pampers
and soap and deodorants
and over-the-counter medications
and the other household
items that were needed.
So we would give these grand families
a small monetary grant
to help do those things
and buy the things that they needed
that they couldn't get
with the food stamps.
(audience applauding)
- That's really amazing.
The project has, it's
had its ups and downs,
but you're dedicated to
keep it going, right?
- Oh yeah, it's been rough
because we're, all of our
finances are generated
through donations, contributions.
And so, there have been
times I'm thinking,
"This has got to end, we
can't do it any longer."
Then about five years ago,
a grandmother with a little
five year old grandson came in
and as I was preparing the food for them,
he was drawing this little picture.
Well, he gave me the picture
and it was a picture of a rainbow.
At one end of the rainbow
was a bag of food.
The other end of the rainbow
was a little stick figure lady.
And that, he said that was me.
- [Kelly] Oh.
- And it just touched my heart
that his gold of that rainbow at the pot,
the gold at the end of the pot,
was just a bag of food.
So God told me no, it's
not time to stop this.
The assignment is not over.
We must continue to try and
help these grand families.
(audience cheering)
- Oh my gosh, that was...
Did you hold it together
when you saw that drawing?
'Cause I'm not doing well, Joyce.
That was so sweet.
Oh my gosh.
And that's gotta make you feel good.
You know you're on the
right path, you know?
When something like that happens,
you know that you're supposed to be,
this is what you're,
you're the vessel for it, you know?
And that's a beautiful
thing to be reminded of,
especially when things get hard
and you're trying to help people.
So thank you so much, Joyce.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience applauding)
And that's not all, Joyce.
Our season long partner,
pilot pen makers of FriXion,
the go-to erasable pen of
"The Kelly Clarkson Show"
want to celebrate those
creating fearlessly
and just being awesome, just like you.
So they're gonna give you $1,000.
How's that sound?
(audience cheering)
- Oh my goodness. Thank you so much.
Much needed and much appreciated.
- All right.
Hey Joyce, I'm gonna throw
in an extra thousand dollars as well.
'Cause I just think what
you're doing is really cool.
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much for joining us!
- Thanks so much.
- And thank you
- for what you do, Joyce.
- We appreciate that.